hi I'm baby wood
hi I'm Mason Gooding hi I'm George sit
up my Benji hi my name is Rachel son and
I play Mia hi I'm Michael Cimino
I played Victor Salazar and today we're
gonna take a BuzzFeed quiz to see which
love think your character first how
would your BFFs describe you loyal
friendly bold smarts creative and
impulsive I think I'm like two of these
you reckon which so you're so you're
impulsive I think I'm just go with it
right that's one kind before you smile
right you worry
I'd say smart old guy would say that I
feel like I put the amount of like
things you do musically and like writing
wise creative making this hard for me
right now I'll do creative what do you
guys think for you yeah what about you
amazing I think smart smart I would say
smart also loyal I say loyal yeah yeah
definitely save oil I since you guys are
my BFFs I guess I'll say oil but that's
what I was gonna say for for Bello was
loyal yeah Anthony um which I offended
if ice if I said impulsive would that be
bad do you think I'm impulsive
you know you choose a rom-com 10 Things
I Hate About You the wedding singer
Sixteen Candles When Harry Met Sally the
big sick or to all the boys I've loved
before
I'm definitely sixteen Candles
I'm between that and 10 Things I Hate
About You I don't know a big sick
honestly and I definitely cried at all
the boys I've loved before also a
curveball and say I'll say when hearing
that something so a huge molly ringwald
plan so I think it's either bad or
heroin hearing that Sally but I think
I'm gonna go with sixteen Candles I just
see Adam Sandler on the wedding singer
so I'm gonna choose that one I'm gonna
set it Big Love - hey Fletcher
10 Things I Hate About You choose a
class to attend one the site - history
of EDM 3 feminism and pop music for
street fighting and physics that's
pretty cool selfie or tree climbing
street fighting and then George has no
option but to choose what you want now I
mean it's not gonna be the arm for
selfie I wanted to say tree climbing
because I have quite both legs and
apparently that means like your
ancestors climbed a lot of trees tree
fighting and physics taking that one
that one's not it yeah I kind of want to
do that one because it's cool but I yeah
I feel like if I took funny ism apart
much about like modern pop music so I
feel like I could actually really need
that like I need the class but also
treat my anger I love a good tree climb
you know feminism and pop music I feel
like I eventually get to like a lot of
artists I love which street fighting and
physics just makes me think of anime
which makes me really happy I'm going
feminism and pop music which loves Simon
character would you trust with a secret
Simon spear brand Greenfield Emily Spier
Cal price Lea Burke or mr. works I think
I know already I would choose Bram I
just
most trustworthy I don't know if I'm
honest like Simon's friends did not
react the best you know starts reading I
don't know it just brands the most
trustworthy period
I'm gonna go Emily because she's a
therapist and I think liebelei she has
to keep my secrets
Bella what are you thinking I think I'm
just gonna go I think that's a good idea
I just worry that my love of Simon is
inciting my decisions so I'll go the
polar opposite and say mr. worth because
I love him and he makes me laugh I just
like mr. worth is probably really easy
to talk to but I wouldn't trust him with
the secret you know I love Simon's mom
yes I love brand but I'm gonna go with
Jennifer I think I'm gonna go Emily
Spier yeah mom I want to go with that as
well for me personally I'm a little brim
choose something important from love
Victor stoplight party DJ f-bomb
increase logistics suspect or Eid Benjy
Creek secrets or the ferris wheel can we
just like mention how I'm devastated I
never saw Anthony in the DJ f bomb suit
like yeah Rachel and I never saw him in
that costume ever
I didn't see the costume I really liked
the cake I just don't like find a
connection to them I like I think I
might know if it's real it just kicks
your gorge here you go first
yeah we had a good time in the ferris
wheel we did we all did I think i'ma
choose DJ f-bomb just for the memes I'm
gonna go for ya yeah one off I'm going
DJ f-bomb yeah yeah come on something
important it's always gonna be
DJ Apple fun fact the Trib tres leches
cake on set was actually vegan and not
really touched my heart that they went
that extra mile to accommodate so
Michael and his veganism so I'm gonna
pick the tres leches the ferris wheel is
very iconic so I think I'm gonna join
with Anthony here and say DJ f-bomb
choose a TV couple Cheryl and
from Riverdale David and Patrick from
shits Creek Alina and cyd from one day
at a time
Magnus and Alec from shadow hunters
Callie and Arizona from Grey's Anatomy
and Kurt and Blaine from Glee oh boy
Elena and said from one day at a time
cuz that's the best show I would
definitely say Kurt and Blaine from Glee
because that was the first time I had
like question my sexuality so deeply
because or what's a Kurt and Blaine from
Glee because I loved an Chris I'm gonna
go Magnus and Alec from Shadowhunters
I'm gonna go one day at a time to rep
James I'm watching Glee right now
so immediately my eye goes to curtain
blame oscillate Callie and Arizona from
Grey's Anatomy though Oh Callie in
Arizona my parents are watching shits
Creek right now so I'm gonna go with
David Patrick I think I'm gonna go with
Kurt and Blaine can we I do choose
something to binge watch on whoo little
fires everywhere
shrill Remi normal people 10:15 or
Looking for Alaska
this is a hard wine pen15 is really good
my friend Dallas is in that show so
shout out to Dallas I'm honest I'm a big
effective team I feel like I'm gonna
leave normal people to you George
because you're like the year your
European and that's like it's a really
good show so yeah okay with that I mean
okay already a hundred percent Rami
I've been telling y'all to watch Rami
for ages he has been doing that she has
been telling us wash that for you yes
she has go with little fires I'm going
normal people cuz I like the accent I'm
also gonna pick little fires everywhere
because that's the only one I haven't
watched yet
I got me a go Victor No Oh interesting
I got you yes no Felix well I got Felix
no I got no injury yeah I got Mia
funnily enough it says my personality
matches Mia you're creative intelligent
and loving you're all around great for
Oh Mia is a great person that definitely
fits me your personality matches Felix
like Felix you're super enthusiastic and
ready for almost anything says your
personality matches Victor you're smart
open-minded and a bit of an introvert
well at times you might feel a little
lost you realize that you're right your
absolute best when you're staging
yourself
I think they might see you with that is
not about right I think so yeah your
personality matches Andrew you're
dependable impulsive and a natural-born
leader while some might find you
intimidating which happen
deep down you have a heart of gold which
is also true they nailed it your
personality matches Mia
you're creative intelligent loving like
Mia you have a hard time opening up to
people you're an all-around great person
and people just wish they could be as
cool as you which is true I wish I was
cool you wrinkle your personality
matches Victor while at times you might
feel a little lost you've realized that
you're at your absolute best when you
stay true to yourself which is which is
a true step in your personality matches
Felix you're loyal fun and understanding
you're not always the best at first
impressions but once people get to know
you they can't help
[Music]